The Spanish government
just passed january 11 the new gecko law
which regulates the collective management of workers
and that it is undoubtedly
1 excellent news for all migrants.
What is this law about?
This law allows hiring people outside Spain
and outside the Spanish regulatory system,
i.e.,
people who do not have the possibility
to get the papers done
that will allow you to work up to 9 months per year
in 1 4-year period.
And only some of the countries that make up
part of this new law are Argentina,
Paraguay,
Mexico,
Ecuador,
Guatemala,
Colombia,
Dominican Republic and many more
where in these works
employees
will receive more or less 1 salary of €1,000 per month
depending on the work they do.
Have you heard of this new regulation?